He's American literature,
Titan of terror,
the writer who created some of the most iconic names in Scifi and there's 46
short years of life.
HP Lovecraft was responsible for the alien God Catula,
the necronomicon book of the dead and the whole entire town of [inaudible] where
things always go bump in the night.
He inspired everyone from Stephen King to Jorge.
Luis Borges has to the writers of Batman.
His work is so penetrated pop culture that you can even buy a plush toys of his
creepiest monsters.
Yesterday,
HP Lovecraft was a man virtually unknown in his lifetime,
living as a recluse in Rhode Island's,
he created a sprawling fictional universe,
the fused traditional horror with cutting edge science in new and revolutionary
ways,
and then he died before more than a handful of people could read it.
In the video today,
we explore how this virtual home has overcame sickness,
isolation,
and his own foul prejudices to become the 20th centuries master of horror.
Okay.
One of the recurring themes in Lovecraft's work is ordinary families hiding dark
secrets in their lineage.
You don't have to look too hard to find the inspiration.
For this.
When August the 20th 1890 Howard Phillips Lovecraft was born into the stately
ancestral home of one of the oldest families in Providence.
His mother's side were wealthy aristocrats with rumors of inbreeding in their
backgrounds while his father was a traveling salesman already suffering from
undiagnosed syphilis before young Howard was even three,
his dad had a nervous breakdown brought on by his disease and he was confined as
to a lunatic asylum.
Although the old man lived in another five years,
Lovecraft had never see him again despite the obvious bag Lovecraft's mother
Sarah tried to give her child a relatively normal life.
The two moved in with her father,
the incredibly wealthy,
gloriously mustachioed whipple van Buren,
Phillips.
It was here that Lovecraft got his first taste for the uncanny.
One of ripples.
Party tricks was to invent trining ghost stories just off the cuff,
much to the delight of his grandson,
still whipple cousins makeup for the obvious hole in young Lovecraft's life from
almost the day that his father collapsed.
Lovecraft was paralyzed by psychological maladies.
At the age of six,
he began having night terrors of faceless men that were so acute that he would
be left trembling for days.
Perhaps it's no surprise that he burning attended school well that Sarah was
raising a dumb dumb.
We're both house was stacked with books.
Even Danzy missed school.
Lovecraft,
who was reading his way through the Arabian nights through Edgar Allan Poe and
even into scientific journals.
By 1898 Lovecraft was a self declared atheist scientist producing his own
homemade made magazines on geology.
Strange as his childhood was.
It was at least stable,
but sadly that's not something that would last.
On march the 27th of 1904 whipple suffered a massive stroke.
He died the next day immediately Lovecraft's life.
It was turned completely upside down.
It turns out Whipple's finances had been badly mismanaged within days of his
death.
The of Croft and his mother,
Sarah,
were evicted from the house and forced to move into a cramped apartment.
The shock was so great.
This Lovecraft by now a boy of 14 contemplator drowning himself and the
Barrington river,
although it wouldn't come out into the open for a few more years.
The day we pulled died is effectively the day that Sarah and her son both when
mad in 1908 Lovecraft would suffer a catastrophic breakdown largely related to
the tragedy,
unable to finish high school,
been able to attend university.
He locked himself away with his mother,
cutting off all contact from society over the next five years.
The past relationship at talent toxic if we Paul's death or damaged Lovecraft's
it had twisted Sarah.
She became verbally abusive towards her teenage son calling him grow task and
telling him to never leave her side.
By 1913 the two were living as codependent recluses Lovecraft's.
He never left home before sunset and spend his endless free time doing nothing.
Bitter reading pulp magazines.
It's at this time that he seems to have developed both crippling social anxiety
and is abnormal fear of the cold in shorts Lovecraft's life.
There was painfully depressing poor backing in friends and goals.
He was in danger of simply vanishing from the history books,
but his life was about to be saved by the unlikeliest of heroes,
a romance novelist.
You've probably never heard of Fred Jackson that,
how'd you mentioned his name to HP Lovecraft.
In 1913 the Rhode Island's recluse would have vomited up blood ashamed of this
trash merchants Pyrex excellence.
Jackson's is in sippet tales of cliched loved stuff.
The pages of the Argosy and magazine Lovecraft,
perhaps somewhat masochistically often ret finally fed up with this hack.
Lovecraft did exactly what any angry weirdo living alone with his mum would do.
He totally trolled him.
Three 1913 Lovecraft sent a sea of letters to the Argosy attacking Jackson's
lack of talents and each time he did it in rhyme.
It was a bizarre thing to do.
It was almost childish,
but it was the thing that actually made Lovecraft's Korea.
By 1914 this weird letter writer has reached the attention of Edward F das
presidents of the United Amateur Press Association.
The Uae Pa intrigues Dasa,
read some of Lovecraft's Andy Jackson poems.
Apparently he likes them.
He offered Lovecraft a job and so began one of the unlikeliest literary careers
in history,
perhaps flattered by Dawson's attention to the 24 year old Lovecraft's took two
amateur press work like an unspeakable.
See Demon water.
He rose assays,
published magazines,
composed poems.
He even finally left as mother's stifling embrace and made some friends and good
job too because it was those friends who convinced him to try his hand at
fiction.
Lovecraft's had written fiction stories as a child,
but never really anything serious until the summer of 1917 that was when the now
27 year old Lovecraft sat down and wrote Dagon the story of a ship wreck sailor
who finds himself trapped and mysterious island filled with the ruins of some
hideous civilization.
Dagon is a short,
creepy piece that already contains the seeds of Lovecraft's greatest works.
It's freezing.
Read online by the way,
if he fancies and my homework,
but the important point is that this is the moment.
This is the moment when love to the weird lonely recluse vanished hens love
Croft to the weird lonely writer arrived.
Not that this transition came without tragedy.
In 1919 Lovecraft's mother's Sarah had a total breakdown confined to the same
lunatic asylum.
Our husband died and she spent two more years raving before finally dying
herself in May of 1921 suddenly often still too strange to fend for himself.
Love graft was taken in by a snobbish ons.
Lillian Clark and and he,
he Phillips GAM.
Well,
this would not be a happy relationship,
but before we dive into that,
it's time we introduced the last significant character in the life of HP
Lovecraft.
Sonya huffed green,
a Russian Jews seven years.
Loved Croft Senior Sonja was a phase noon on the amateur,
pressing independently wealthy from how successful hat store sheet bankrolled
several low budget magazine that eight two weeks off to Sarah's death.
Sonia was visiting a UAP,
a convention in Boston when she was introduced to the new knee orphan Lovecraft.
Somehow the two hit it off,
well followed.
It wasn't exactly a Fred Jackson's style romance.
Love Croft was so disinterested in sex that Sonia had to cut journeyman's making
love by giving him textbooks on romance to study.
Perhaps not surprisingly,
she would lay to claim Lovecraft was a virgin when they met.
Still the two really did like one another.
On March the third 1924 they went in a secret ceremony only informing
Lovecraft's disapproving aunts by letter,
not long.
Officer Lovecraft left Rhode Island's and moved in with so near in New York.
There was spring 1924 and life was good.
Lovecraft was having his first stories professionally published in weird tales
and sending us how to business was booming,
things they were finally getting on track,
excepts of course it couldn't last.
Sonia was unwell.
By the end of 1924 her illness was eating up so much of her time,
but the hap sharp had gone bust.
Loved crafted.
Meanwhile,
bungled is one shot at a stable income by turning down the opportunity to add
arrival,
a pulp magazine.
Weird Tales come Christmas of 1924 the two what broke on January the first 1925
Sonia moved alone to Cleveland to take up a job left behind in New York.
Lovecraft rented a tiny apartment in Brooklyn's notorious red hook.
It was a mistake that would hold him for the rest of his life.
Lovecraft hated rhetoric.
He absolutely hated it,
surrounded by immigrants suddenly alone and broke again.
He descended into a twisted business that found it's expression in the worst
kind of racism.
Yes,
it's time for us.
Talk about the demonic elder God in the room.
Lovecraft was a bounding,
are racist.
That sort of person,
it's hard to believe exists outside of daily stormer.
Message boards in 1912 for example,
age 22 he had written a poem referring to black people as beasts and semi human
figures.
He was also a raging anti-semite.
He wants roads of New York City.
The population is a Mongrel herd with repulsive mongoloid Jews in the visible
majority and as the course faces and bad manners eventually come to where?
On one so unbearably that one feels like punching every God damn bastard in
sight.
Yikes.
Let's dweeby accused of unfair treatment.
We should note here that Lovecraft's racism was more complex than it first
appears.
You probably remember from 10 minutes ago that his wife,
Sonia,
was herself Jewish.
Well,
she wasn't the only Jewish friend.
That Lovecraft hat tablet magazine notes that the pope writer Robert Bloch who
would later pen the novel Alfred Hitchcock's psycho is based on.
It was a friend of Lovecraft's and so was the poet Samuel Loveman.
Love grew up then with a man who was openly racist,
but in the abstract sense faced with people he personally likes.
He weren't White Protestants.
Lovecraft seemed to have no problems.
Discarding is racial beliefs,
not that there weren't many people love Croft liked in red hook though as an ID
25 drags on the reclusive writers,
feelings towards foreigners turns into something close to horror.
The dreads he felt surrounded by a sea of non white faces turned into a genuine
phobia.
It's since been argued that this phobia influenced Lovecraft's work itself with
his tales of nameless forces and unknowable aliens.
It's not too much of a stretch to think that Lovecraft was simply channeling his
inner feelings towards New York's multicultural population.
If that is the case,
well at least we can save that something good came of his very poisonous
thoughts.
By early 1926 Lovecraft had had enough.
He wrote to his aunt's Linnaean and Annie begging them for help.
The two agreed to engineer his return to Providence,
but at a price Sonia would not move to Rhode Islands and she would never see a
husband again,
exhausted,
desperate to get away from the city.
He hated so much.
Lovecraft agreed,
although he's still claim to love Sonia.
He moved back to providence on April the 17th 1926 and he would never see his
wife again
in some of 1926 the hideous creature rose out of the waters of the South
Pacific,
a monster,
a vaguely anthropoid outline,
but with an octopus like head whose face was a mess of feelers,
a Scaly,
rubbery looking body,
prodigious clause on the hind and four feet and long barrow wing's behind the
monster tower,
not just over all who saw it,
a bit over horror fiction itself.
It's name was Cathy Hulu,
and it was to become the most important of all of Lovecraft's creations.
The star of a short story.
The cool of Kathy Luca [inaudible] was Lovecraft's first creation after
returning to providence and elder gone to biding his time in the depths of the
sea waiting for the moment humanity will awaken him and destroy the worlds
through new has gripped our imaginations ever since this even a region on Pluto
named after him.
Yes,
at the moment.
He first raised is unspeakable head from the waves could through new seemed
destined.
Obscurity newly arrived back from New York.
Love Croft had little hope for his latest Amman,
steady on the small paycheck and some fleeting recognition.
Luckily,
the his friends,
they had other ideas.
Do you remember we talked about how Lovecraft finally made some real friends off
to join you.
The UAP a way back in 1914 well,
over the years,
that evolved into quite the little circle of pen pals among the number where
robots block of psycho fame.
Robert Howard,
the creator of Conan the barbarian ans writer,
August,
done with who's about to become really,
really important.
It's in about five minutes.
When these guys read cathedral,
they went absolutely nuts.
Cathedral,
it was something new.
They encouraged everyone in Lovecraft circle to start writing their own tails
set in the same universe over the next decade.
The grip would build up something called the [inaudible] ethos.
It's the reason we still remember the character of [inaudible] today.
At the same time as this mythos was growing,
Lovecraft wins through his most productive streak is a writer.
Something about moving back to Rhode Island's has energized him and a handful of
years he wrote some of his greatest hits,
the color out of space,
the case of Charles Dex towards the shadow of ins mouth and the mountains of
madness.
If you don't have to love Croft Fan,
just know that this is like the Beatles knocking out sergeant pepper,
the white album,
yellow submarine and Abbey Road,
one after the other.
It was a muster working at his peak come during vistas of Psych,
clippy and alien cities and Eldridge horizontal like anything readers had ever
experienced before.
Luftwaffe may have been living in semi poverty with too domineering aunts and no
access to the woman he loved,
but it was clearly doing wonders for his productivity.
Even the Bruising Wall Street crash of 1929 fail to dentists newfound enthusiasm
as the 19th that he's got underway.
He was scraping together enough funds to take loan joints along the coast of his
beloved New England's.
But if there's one thing we've learned about Lovecraft's life so far,
it's that all good things must come to a terrible ends and soon enough they did.
Yeah.
In 1932 Lovecraft's aren't.
Lillian Clark died despite her overbearing personality.
Lovecraft was devastated.
He and his surviving arms Annie,
were forced to move into a tiny apartments.
It was the beginning of a long slide into grinding poverty.
Lovecraft may have been writing his greatest work at this point,
but his greatest work,
it was long,
complex stuff and it has no mass appeal.
What he and then he needed work short,
punchy tales that he could sell regularly.
Not something like the Antarctic horror of at the mountains of madness,
which took five years to find a buyer.
The love graphs have too much integrity or perhaps too much stupidity to lower
his standards.
Ponies on ghost writing work in order to survive.
Way Back in 1924 had ghostwritten into south of Harry Houdini and the two had
become friends,
so maybe this would be just as rewarding.
Sadly,
it was not to be the ghost writing of Lovecraft's final years took up all of his
time and left him drains and just pour.
Has it ever been,
he took to eating tens of expired food in order to survive and that was only
when he could afford to eat at all.
Perhaps one of the positive achievements Lovecraft made in these gloomy years
was to keep up his letter writing from the days of his trolling as is to the
Augusti.
Lovecraft had composed letters with a commitments rarely seen before or since
it's estimated he sent a hundred thousand letters in his lifetime,
second only to the great French philosopher Voltaire.
By spring 1936 Lovecraft had almost given up on his fiction,
his own.
These stories since 1933 had been the shadow out of time.
Now considered a late class seconds,
the creepy but short hunter of the dark.
So why this sudden lack of interest in alien worlds,
but it may have been because Lovecraft had found something else to write about.
In the Cold New England winter of 1935 to 1936 Lovecraft had begun documenting
an illness that he was suffering from that he called the grip.
This script was actually cancer as 1936 war on it,
ate away at his intestines until his insides.
What riddled with tumors like the Rec Lucy was Lovecraft refuse to see a doctor
that's on the more bad news came Robert Howard,
the Conan writer and friend of Lovecraft committed suicide by shooting himself
in the head.
The death of his pen pal sent Lovecraft's spiraling into depression from which
he never fully recovered.
By spring 1937 it was all as you clear that something was deeply wrong.
Lovecraft had written nothing but four poems in over a year.
He was in constant agony and consumed by black thoughts.
Often he would sit alone at night in the cold and gloomy apartments haunting the
darkened room like one of his own creations.
On march the 10th 1937 the pain and finally became too much.
Lovecraft checked himself into the Jane Brown Memorial Hospital,
but by now the cancer had gone far too beyond what any treatment could take care
of.
Five days later on March the 15th of 1937 HP Lovecraft passed away and his last
moments.
It's possible the ones in what would become of his work after he died.
If he did,
we can only assume that he thought his writings scattered across cheap pulp
magazines would soon be forgotten,
but he had encountered on August Dartmouth
rather,
how we mentioned that August data.
If it was one of Lovecraft's writer friends and was going to be really,
really important to this story at some points,
well this is points often.
Lovecraft died.
Delyth decided to give the old their literary send off that he deserved.
In August of 1939 Duluth founded [inaudible] house publishes specifically to put
out hardback additions of Lovecraft stories.
The outsider and others is a at the same,
yeah,
runs was resoundingly not a success.
It's advanced orders came to him in 150 copies when one wound up at the New York
has officers,
they gave it a dreadful review.
But here's the thing about Dartmouth.
He may have been a hack writer who utterly failed to grasp what Lovecraft was
trying to do with this fiction,
but he was a loyal friends and he was also a friend who just happened to have
very deep pockets.
Over the next few years to UNEF kept all come house afloat,
pushing out volume after volume of Lovecraft's tales.
He even had them translated into foreign languages.
This turned out to be an excellent move over in postwar France.
The French translations of Lovecraft's well became hugely popular.
It helps that Paris intellectuals already considered and to go around and
there's a retired and then none of Lovecraft was clearly posed.
20th Century success up by the 1960s Lovecraft Croft was so popular abroad that
it made financial sense for all can house to rerelease his story state side.
The timing simply couldn't have been better.
Lovecraft reappeared on the scene just as a new wave of films was making horror
popular again,
raising Mary's baby night of the living dead knocked.
You mentioned the first us release of Britain's hammer horror films sparked a
surge of interest in weird fiction legions of people you'd never read horror or
Saifai flocked to Lovecraft.
But in the 1970s the gentleman from providence at a serious fan base,
what followed,
was a dizzying embrace of an offer who'd only ever risen football magazines.
In 1974 Batman's writers borrowed the idea of Arkham asylum from Lovecraft's.
In 1977 Superfan,
Stephen King exploded onto the literary scene with Carrie and spent the rest of
his career encouraging others to read Lovecraft.
That same year,
a group of American fans cobbled together enough cash to replace Lovecraft small
tombstone with a gigantic state.
Anyone battering the legend I providence the culture of Lovecraft's link the
cults that gather around the great cathedral and his stories could no longer be
ignored in the year since that myth of love,
Croft has only grown.
Today's story's invented the Canon of American fiction,
both penguin classics and Library of America for at least volumes.
People as diverse as Neil Gaiman,
Alan Moore,
and gamma to Tara have been influenced by him.
He's arguably the best known horror writer whose name isn't and go them Pyre,
but perhaps the best way to explain the enduring appeal of HP Lovecraft is
through the words of Erica Henderson,
the marvel artist,
responsible for squirrel girl speaking to the Guardian in 2013 she said,
love Croft made a world where humans are alone floating on a rock and a
terrifying larger universe that we cannot possibly comprehend because our time
in this has been so short and we are so insignificant compared to the horrors
from the cathedral ethos.
So much of modern horror is based on that idea.
We wouldn't have Ghostbusters who went for Lovecraft's,
and that's the best arguments that I can think of for his work.
He may have been a widow,
he may have held despicable beliefs,
but Lovecraft was an artist who would come to influence the very way that we
think about horror from his twisted mind.
He brought us nightmares we'd never even dreamed of before.
Nice manners that still haunt us to this very day.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
Also,
if you're looking for something else,
I've got another channel called top tens.
We do top 10 lists.
We've got authors on there as well as lots of other people and just interesting
facts.
So go check that out.
You'll find a link to it below,
as well as on the screen.
And as always,
thank you for watching.